you
hi everyone it's Jerry 1997 marked an
important time in chess history that was
when IBM's deep blue became the first
computer to win a match against a
reigning world champion Garry Kasparov
fast forward two decades computers
nowadays are well beyond the play of
humans today 2017 also marks an
important time in chess history the
deepmind division at Google headquarters
has already tackled the game of Go and
now it's looking to conquer chess and it
appears that they have with the program
alpha 0 alpha zero is equipped with two
key components one deep neural networks
which is a way to process information
that are inspired by biological systems
like the brain and to a general
reinforcement learning algorithm that
basically means alpha zero knows nothing
beyond the rules of the game no opening
Theory no endgame tablebases it simply
plays from scratch and continually
improves from every game it plays
against itself well certainly learned by
playing against itself it did this for
just four hours and then went on to
defeat the 2016 top chess engine
champion stockfish eight in a 100 game
match let that sink in for a moment
chess is nearly 1500 years old and after
all these years spent acquiring
knowledge about the game were bested by
alpha zero after it learned for just
four hours the final tally the final
result of this 100 game match alpha zero
128 games with 72 draws in every good
math student knows how many losses the
game I like to share with you alpha zero
is playing with the black pieces this is
one of three games alpha zero one with
black there is an advantage playing with
the white pieces having the first move
of the game is an advantage so how did
alpha zero managed to win when playing
with black let's find out
we have an e4 e5 game Ray Lopez Berlin
defense I'm running stockfish eight on
my system as I play through this game by
the way not the same hardware as what
was used for the match if you're
interested in that information the
hardware check out the link in the
description for that and much more
information there's a 19 page PDF about
this match
continuing d3 Bishop c5 chop chop that
right there is the first capture and
we're not gonna see another one for
about 40 moves a lot of maneuvering goes
on in this one
there's only 10 games by the way that
have been made available to the public
ten of the 100 games I'm really
interested in seeing these other 90 so
let's get on that Google can we see
these other 90 it's uh
I'm interested and I'm sure many viewers
are interested in seeing these other
alpha0 games so Bishop d6 this guy here
by the way does not budge for I believe
the rest of the game he stays put
there's some pressure applied to him and
he is reinforced numerous times as we'll
see with the Queen first a pawn next
eventually a rook defends e5 a5 is there
to expand on the Queen side I have some
Queen side space Queen c2 Knight f8 and
after this structural change c4 c5 we
have d5 an interesting moment in the
game a pretty static structure for sure
it's a maneuvering game many instance is
a fixed pawn a fixed a center d5 is one
of just a few moves white makes in
blacks position we have d5 we have much
later on a simple capture on defy or
really a recapture on d5 and once we're
at a point where white is already lost
we'll see a move from a4 and a5 but
beyond that beyond these three simple
moves in blacks position there's really
no other action white isn't isn't even
allowed to really step foot in blacks
house so let's see how things progress a
little stabilizing move with b6 this
Knight is eyeing up f5 but alpha zero
has you know that's just not going to
happen Knight f3
Bishop d7 things are looking you know
equal ish little actually stock fish ate
right now is a plus point five and was
even a little bit more just a moment ago
but after h3 this is another point in
the game that I'd like to touch on the
one that I find interesting the ten
games that have been released they were
all all had their interesting points but
what I liked about this is that alpha
zero one with black of course and it
apparently already understands that this
is a position where white struggles to
find a constructive pawn break where is
there a a good pawn break for white that
will
let's say improve the quality of the
pieces I don't see it
unfortunately for white we're going to
observe a lot of nothing moves
non-committal
shuffling King moves Bishop moves
meanwhile black is able to slowly make
some progress let's see how this is done
these are very interesting a very very
slick maneuver that black pulls off here
Queen g7 we're not we're not quite at
that point but it's it's it's it's
nearby a three page six
Bishop to h4 I'd like you to take note
of these positions right here the bishop
in the rook this is the first time we're
seeing this position right here Bishop
on g3 rook on e7 Bishop h4 is played
route to f7 Bishop g3 is played the rook
returns to e7 this is now the second
time the second instance of this very
position why am i drawing attention to
this well
light continues with Bishop to h4
wrote to f7 and white goes back to g3
what does this mean what is one way to
maybe interpret this well
if alpha zero wants a draw if alpha zero
wants this game to be over it'll move
this rook to e7 in the game becomes a
draw
due to threefold repetition it's one of
the rules black with the next move says
play ball no drum a form clamping down
on these two pawns black wants more
so apparently alpha zero recognizes that
it's better here even though you know
we're seeing on the screen stockfish is
slightly better again not the same
hardware but yeah apparently alpha zero
thinks it's a it's better here otherwise
it it would have gone for the repetition
I would think what do I know what do we
know
let's see King - h1 this is what I mean
by a bit of a nothing move you can't you
don't know if the King is any better on
g1 than h wonders it's just a passing
non-committal move so rook to e7 this is
another case where take note of these
two positions currently bishop on g3
rook on f7 rookie seven bishop h4 rook
f7 rook g3 this is now the second time
we have this same position rook to e7
Bishop h4 if alpha zero moves this rook
now to this square
that gives white an opportunity to
return to g3 and claim a threefold
repetition once more alpha zero says no
I want more g5 is played bishop g3
Knight g6 this is a beautiful square for
the knight possible jumping points on f4
and h4 but now black is preparing to
simply negate the knight Knight e3 is
met with Knight to e7 fighting for the
f5 square clean to d3 and now black as
mentioned earlier is going to make some
steady progress kicking out first with
an expansion on the kingside h5 h4 and
now Knight to c8 the beginning of a very
nice maneuver
a habit pointed this out yet but this
Bishop has been suffering from tall pond
syndrome uh he does not belong there the
most efficient piece to blockade the d5
pawn is a knight why
well he's not completely defensive like
the bishop for one he's actually a very
good attacking piece putting pressure on
the e 4 and C 4 points so this is what
we're gonna have G for the queen is
getting out of the way so the bishop can
go to a much more active diagonal and
the knight can simply drop into d6 this
is a wonderful a way to reposition the
pieces very very instructive King to g1
again a lot of nothing moves by white
the Knights looking for a c3 Knight d6
Bishop to h6 rip to f1 that move is very
difficult I just do not know what in the
world is going on with rikta aah I guess
maybe anticipating some break over here
or some pressure against a four I cannot
really say what's going on with that
move
so we see a shift in the evaluation by
the way it's already it's in the
negatives now stockfish is not liking
its position and it's just going to get
worse so we have the king coming over
towards the center with still all this
traffic on board it may seem a little
bit crazy to do this but there is some
security with the king being on the e6
square so bishop for Knight exchange not
sure how good the bishops are in these
locked positions really the the key
pieces in this position are the Knights
and let's take it take these posts into
account
night comparison who's doing better it's
definitely the Black Knight he's putting
pressure on the white pieces that
require the defense of white pieces
meanwhile this knight is staring at his
own pawns and squares that he's never
going to be able to successfully jump
into these forward moves by the white
knight are all no good
either illegal or just yeah he's negated
very easily white is on the defensive
white also if we compare the King
positions is much better off the white
King stands on a half-open file for
black meanwhile the black King is on a
closed file black has a much more secure
King and will find it much easier to
shift pieces now over towards the King
side of the board what will the White
King do let's find out Bishop - eh Queen
h7 that's just anticipating rook g3 so
we're going to have some major pieces
coming off one rook and now a second
rook the Queen's and in minor pieces
Queen is looking to invade Knight to d2
prevents this a growing advantage as we
can see from the stockfish eight engine
I'm running King h2 King to d7 is
probably the better square staying on a
light square so he's not going to ever
move and give check so white tries to
make some progress over here on the
Queen side with a pawn move this is not
helping this pawn you know he's still
both of these guys here still gonna
remain weak so Queen to g6 you have to
defend efore so night there and that
that is blocking the the Queen site of
d1 so blacks able to now sneak the
bishop in well beyond well behind enemy
lines here
looking for some maneuver Bishop to a
form at any point if white is not
careful this bishop can get into
position to maybe hunt down the c-4 pond
so the white pieces constantly have to
keep a watchful eye over these points
it's all because of this knight on d6
that great reposition that we saw
getting into the d6 square so a lot of
things progress here we're eventually
going to have a queen exchange and now
this King is way out of play and without
the Queen around these guys easily fall
to both the bishop and night they can be
attacked twice and there could only ever
be one defender and he's it meanwhile
wherever this bishop goes he's just
biting on rocks what do you do techie
five tech f5 does nothing so what is
tried is this little breaking up type
thing softening up the c5 square White's
trying to get at this point but the
knight is there prepared to meet a five
with Knight takes pawn keeping the
structure as is in other words
eventually we're gonna have these pawns
drop there isn't a good way to defend c6
break is in this is what I meant by one
of the moves in blacks position a simple
recapture which is really not like a
move in blacks position a recapturing
move like that but black is now up one
pawn this King is finally getting
involved he was way out of play and
we're gonna have the Knights off an
opposite colored Bishop bending an
outside past pawn which is very valuable
and eventually the black King is able to
make some progress where is he headed
the bishop controls this pawn advance
the King is headed for this square here
where he simply Forks those two pawns
and is gonna win one so that's exactly
what happens nothing much that black can
do about that it's a second pawn one for
alphago or excuse me alpha zero and
after we get to this point here King to
e6 move 87 stockfish has had enough this
is where the game ends stockfish throws
in the towel if the game continued how
it might play out this is just one of
many ways it could have finished right
down to let's say check me on just throw
all the moves out there that's one fancy
way the game could have ended but in
this one it only got to move 87 right
here after King to e6 stockfish resigns
so this is really I don't know
mind-blowing is one of the terms that
comes to mind here what are your
thoughts of this alpha 0 be sure to
leave a comment below and I'm looking
forward to your replies this is just
some fascinating stuff that we're being
made aware of it's really it's a really
exciting time to be involved with chess
and I'm looking forward to
any comments you have in the comment
section below so as usual feel free to
leave any feedback and I hope you got
something out of this video that's all
for now take care bye
you